the contents of allison's note to rey
so again spoilers feel free to talk
about it and we will have a nice big fat
warning for anyone who hasn't said okay
i know that when you watch movies and
shows sometimes
current events can wind up enhancing
certain themes and ideas but
that note really did feel like it was
speaking to everybody
in the country right now so
over the course of production or
post-production if you know you did like
adr work for something like that did
that speech
evolve at all or was it always written
that way
um it was actually always written that
way i i did adr for it
um a while ago like while we were in
quarantine but it was like before
george floyd it was before this like
black lives matter global
moment that we are in and movement that
we are in um
but i think that you know i think that
is the biggest takeaway for me
and hopefully for so many viewers this
season of just like
we didn't have to rewrite a lot of
alison's story lines to make it current
because like systemic racism has been
present and current in our country and
all over this world but especially in
our country
for 400 years and and i think it has
taken on different faces it has taken on
different names it has taken on
you know you know different it is but
the the fight against that
has taken on it has you know has
different movements and different
moments but it is the same
it is the same thing that is being
fought it is it is the same
struggle that is is is is um
that that you know black americans and
people of color
and and um and you know
black people people of color all over
the world are fighting and i think that
it's it's just really crazy how
relevant how even more relevant this
season
has become because you know i it felt
relevant to me
when we were shooting it but i'm like
now
you know rethinking about some of these
scenes and then some of the things that
allison says you know
in her last conversation with with ray
she says you have to stay because the
fight
the fight the fight is not over even in
2019
it's like we didn't they wrote that they
wrote that a year and a half ago
you know what i mean so it's just like i
just hope that it is shedding
you know just a brighter light on the
fact that you know we just
lost congressman lewis who dedicated his
life to
the fight against injustice so that is
just further proof that that was not
long ago that was that was our
grandparents in our parents lifetime
and ruby bridges who was the first black
child to integrate in all white school
just turned 65. so you know it's like
these are not problems of the past
they are problems and struggles of today
and i just think that the show
is is really just shedding a light on
that and and hopefully
on a massive platform which is really
encouraging and inspiring